[Music]
good morning Johanna
good morning pal I've already got the
best route to your first meeting in ways
ready I've pulled up the new imagine
dragon song on Spotify and set your butt
warmer to 71.5 degrees just like you
like it you are too good to me
play music imagine dragons dysfunction
is only possible with disk USB or iPod
navigate to first meeting sohe's repeat
navigation so he's repeat you think boys
control meant some degree of actual
control but no and even worse this is my
brand new right off the lot car I'm not
asking for much accurate maps and
traffic to listen and control streaming
music safely basic phone calls and an
assistant that understands me of course
those are all right in here
yes the currents not so perfect solution
is using your smartphone safely with the
right gear this is not okay this is
definitely not okay first thing get a
smartphone mount so you don't have to
look down to glance at your screen I
tested 15 different mount options in
three categories number one the vent
mount I like the twenty dollar insignia
vehicle mount the best but no matter
which one you pick you're gonna be down
a vent and that's no fun in the winter
number two the dashboard or windshield
mount the $80 Logitech zero touch dash
mount was the best but it requires you
attach magnets to the back of your phone
or phone case number three the CD slot
mount this $13 anchor CD slot holder was
my favorite but again magnets if you've
got an Android phone pair it with your
car's Bluetooth and download the Android
Auto app it provides a stripped-down
interface and Google Voice control ok
Google
play Third Eye Blind here you go
asking to play third a grind it works
very well when it's quiet ok Google ok
Google ok go go Logitech zero touch app
and mount gets around this high-five the
phone in the air and it initiates
logitech's own voice control navigate to
work it also now works with Amazon's
Alexa Alexa I brush my teeth to my to-do
list disappointingly there's no Android
Auto app equivalent for the iPhone and
the Logitech doesn't work with iOS so
the best thing you can do is rig Siri to
work in the car setup hey Siri hey Siri
play Elton John but it has the same
problem hey Siri hey Siri of course all
of these solutions are just band-aids
they surely beat fighting with my car's
terrible voice assistant and interface
in the meantime I'll keep dreaming of
right on top of that Joanna also you're
beautiful
[Music]
you